[MUSIC PLAYING]
KRISPY UCCELLO: Hello and
welcome to the first episode
of Screen Intensity.
This is a new format that we're
experimenting with where
we've done away with the
Hangouts On Air portion, and
we're instead focusing on
content that will help you,
the developers, understand
Google TV better, the
audiences you can approach,
things you
might want to develop--
be it web apps or Android
applications for TV.
We're going to be using this
format going forward, which
means we'll be launching only
one episode every month.
But within that episode will
be packed three segments--
typically an event coverage
segment, a tutorial, and then
something else that we
decide as we go on.
This month will be a little
different in that we're going
to be covering CES as well as
the LA YouTube Google TV
hackathon that took place
January 26 and
27 at our LA office.
Now, if you want to provide
feedback and give us an
understanding of how you feel
about this format, what you'd
like to see, et cetera, please
feel free to email me at
krispy@google.com.
As well, feel free to create
video questions and hashtag
them with screenintensity.
And I'll start looking for those
to see if we can roll
them into future episodes.
So with that, why don't we get
started and take a look at
what happened at CES.
Hello.
My name is Krispy.
I'm a Developer Programs
Engineer on Google TV, and I'm
joined today with Matt Gaunt
who's a Developer Advocate,
also on Google TV.
And we're going to
talk a little bit
today about CES 2013.
MATT GAUNT: The beast that is.
KRISPY UCCELLO: The
beast that is.
So why don't we lead off.
What was your impression
this year?
This was your first
time, wasn't it?
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, first time in
Vegas, first time at CES.
I was blown away.
It's just phenomenal to see the
number of companies there,
the number of people that are
just passing through looking
at everything that they can
possibly get their hands on.
Yeah, I was amazed,
to be honest.
KRISPY UCCELLO: A lot of treat
bags floating around I'm sure.
MATT GAUNT: So many bags.
KRISPY UCCELLO: So let's talk
about the presence of
Google TV at CES.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, so generally,
the presence of
Google TV, we had a lot of the
team members working there.
We were kind of helping out a
lot of the partner booths,
getting to meet a lot of people
that were coming through.
And generally, everyone that was
there that we spoke to was
either enjoying the new features
that were brought in
V3, or they were telling us
about apps they love or
generally how impressed they
were about the number of
partners that we kind of grew
to and the numbers that were
being announced at CES.
KRISPY UCCELLO: So certainly a
lot more buzz and excitement
and sort of that, wow, when
can we get on there?
MATT GAUNT: Exactly.
It was a really nice mix of new
people that hadn't really
heard of Google TV versus
people that have been
following us since the start and
were just like, wow, you
guys have just completely
exploded.
KRISPY UCCELLO: So what do
you think this means for
developers in the TV
development or
app development space?
MATT GAUNT: So for me, I think
it's always come down to like
any kind of general platform
kind of application.
You get to a point where you
have to pick a platform when
you're starting out.
And generally, when you do that,
you're already targeting
a specific device, and then
instantly, you say, well,
either I target one platform and
it's tied to one sort of
OEM or I can target one platform
that's literally
sported everywhere.
And that's kind of the main
goal of Google TV.
And I think we kind of proved
to the point now that
developers who are looking for
smart TV platforms, they can
go with Google TV and they're
going to start hitting a range
of devices from a range
of different partners.
And at that point, they can
obviously sit there and make
the trade off of, well, if I
go for this, it's one code
base, it's going to run
on all these devices.
It makes a lot of sense.
KRISPY UCCELLO: Now, while you
were sort of cruising the
floor and checking out all the
cool technology there, what
was your favorite
geek-out moment?
Where was that aha, I'm at
CES, this is amazing?
MATT GAUNT: I think for me is
when you start going around
and you start trying out
different things
in the voice commands.
And literally, just someone
showed me a new trick which I
didn't even know existed where
they say there, they pressed
the voice search button,
and just went, how
to tie a bow tie.
And then YouTube just opened
up straight to a video of a
guy just showing you how
to tie a bow tie.
And I just thought,
that's amazing.
KRISPY UCCELLO: Because
bow ties are cool.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, obviously.
But it's just that whole thing
of getting to a point where
you can say a voice search and
then your TV is literally just
coming back with
the first thing
that is the most relevant.
And obviously, it's just
amazing to think
where that could go.
Like, that's one example.
But you start going deeper and
deeper in and how you can
start responding to
these queries.
KRISPY UCCELLO: So developers
often ask, how can I
participate in the voice
search part of this.
So do you want to talk a
little bit about that?
MATT GAUNT: At the moment, the
best way of doing it is if you
start integrating into the Quick
Search Box, which you
can already do on the
Android platform.
Obviously, we're going to get
to a stage where your app is
going to appear in
those results.
But it'd be really nice if we
start getting deeper, like I
hope one day, we have an API
where you can launch
automatically like we
do with YouTube.
But at the moment, the Quick
Search Box, you say a voice
search, it'll come up, it gives
you a list of options.
And then you can start
having your app
service at that point.
So it's still really nice entry
point for a user to kind
of find your content.
KRISPY UCCELLO: And what's a
good place for someone who's
maybe not familiar with
this technology?
Where should they start
digging in?
MATT GAUNT: So for me, I think
the best place is to kind of
start with a really core idea,
a core concept you think
people will really benefit
from and love.
And then start developing
an Android app.
And if you start getting to
that point where you can
release something and publish
it, do it as soon as possible
when you're comfortable with
it, like you think it's
actually good enough.
Because what you start learning
is people will start
responding with feature requests
or they'll start
finding out bugs that you
haven't found yourself.
And then you quickly start
learning about the platform,
you start learning the nuances
of the APIs, et cetera.
And for me, that's the easiest
way of doing it, is if you
start learning on the job, you
start getting people feeding
back to everything that
you're doing.
It's much more organic.
KRISPY UCCELLO: So measurement
is obviously
a big part of this.
So analytics, mobile
analytics, APIs
would play a big role.
But just back to the search
box for a moment.
There's a section in Android
documentation about this?
MATT GAUNT: Yep, so I think
literally if you go to
developers.android.com, there's
a massive search box
right there.
Search Quick Search Box.
Generally, the documentation on
the Android site is great
because you don't just get
an API doc generally.
If you search something like
Quick Search, what you'll get
is almost a blog post style
thing where they start saying,
here's what you're trying to
do, this is how you do it.
And they kind of guide you
through step by step in really
kind of plain English of
what you need to do.
And then when you start saying,
well, I'd really like
it if it could just do this,
that's the point that they'll
kind of say, look at the docs
and you'll find what you need.
KRISPY UCCELLO: Awesome.
So with the talk about voice
search and how excited
everyone is around this, what
other things are we seeing
from device manufacturers that
we haven't seen in the past?
MATT GAUNT: I think the main
thing that I kind of took away
from this, the main difference,
as well as just
the remote's still changing
vastly between each OEM,
they've started adding in this
new button on the buttons
which basically say hide the
cursor or show the cursor.
And basically, it's kind of a
nice way of switching the user
out from having that main
navigation with the gyroscope
or using a touch pad to just
having that up, down, left,
right D-pad.
So yeah, that, for me,
was the big thing
that's kind of changed.
KRISPY UCCELLO: So the
directional pad obviously is
still going to be the primary
mode of input in the future.
It's not going away, but we're
starting to see more--
[INAUDIBLE]
MATT GAUNT: --much, much--
KRISPY UCCELLO: So one
last thing that
we should talk about.
What do you think developers
of TV apps should pay
attention to out of
CES this year?
MATT GAUNT: I think the biggest
kind of thing that
you'll notice when you start
looking at any kind of TV
platform is generally, they try
and make things as simple
and kind of relaxing
as possible.
Like people who are in the
living room interacting with
their TVs, they're trying
to get to some form of
entertainment, generally.
They're in that kind of mode
where they just want to relax
and just be entertained.
And I think the biggest that
developers need to take away
from that is, whatever you do
with your UI, try and keep it
simplistic, try and focus more
on your core functionality and
make it as seamless as possible
to get the user from
entry to where they want
to go in your app.
So for me, it's all about
focusing on the experience and
making sure what they're doing,
they're enjoying, and
just trying to create some
sort of environment and
experience where they're
really enjoying it.
KRISPY UCCELLO: And that's
really what it comes down to--
create an experience.
For those of you who are
watching now, you might be
watching this on the Google
Developers Live Android
application, which is what Matt
and I are working on.
It started out as a seed of
an idea, I protected it.
And Matt has been gracious
enough to help me make the UI
as wonderful as possible.
So do you want to talk a little
bit about what you've
had to do to clean up my trail
blazing code paths?
MATT GAUNT: So I kind of saw
what Krispy was doing.
And one of the main things that
I wanted to do-- well,
the first I wanted to do was
bring it in line a little bit
more with kind of the GDL
design already on
the website, et cetera.
I think there's a really clear
branding already there, and I
kind of wanted to bring
it over to the app.
So I started off doing some
mocks in just my favorite
photo editing software, went
through all of that, and got
to a stage where I was
quite happy with it.
I'd taken input from other
people, including Krispy.
And I thought right, cool.
I'm going to start doing this in
code now because it's going
to be easier and
quicker to make
little changes and tweaks.
But largely, a lot of it was
just pulling out different
fixed widths, fixed paddings,
moving it all into styles in
the values kind of directory,
and generally getting to a
point where everything was
shared and syncing up
with the same page.
At that point, it was nice and
easy just to start making
little tweaks on different
versions whether it be on TV
or tablet or phone.
And yeah, just bringing
everything into one more
coherent thing and making it
work or look slightly more in
line with Android design
guidelines.
Because obviously, Android,
especially over the last kind
of couple of versions, have
really focused on encouraging
developers to have a very
similar look and feel while
still bringing in their own
branding, their own elements
of differentiation, but still
not expecting a user to learn
an entirely new interface.
So I think we found
a good balance.
KRISPY UCCELLO: Right.
And actually, one of the things
that I learned from you
over this was going for a broad
layout architecture as
opposed to a deep one, which is
what I was tending to do.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, generally,
I've learned the hard way.
If you have a layout structure
and you end up having linear
layout, view, linear layout, and
you start going deeper and
deeper and deeper in that kind
of view hierarchy, everything
starts getting slow, everything
starts getting sluggish.
And yeah, one of things I've
just been doing is just
removing redundant views.
So Hierarchy Viewer is a
fantastic tool for this, which
I've just been kind of relying
on quite heavily just to shave
off some of the--
KRISPY UCCELLO: Some of
the cruft I added.
So for developers out there
who are curious, I mean I
don't have very much
Android experience.
Since I've joined the team, I've
started to ramp up on it.
I still consider myself a
generalist and someone
relatively new.
But you've been at
this a while.
MATT GAUNT: Yes, I've been
working on Android since 1.0.
And I've kind of been working
with a number of companies
keeping relatively
up to Android.
I think towards the start of
the tablet world, I think I
started tailing off,
so that's where I'm
still picking out myself.
But yeah, generally, I've kind
of watched Android grow from a
fixed screen width and height
right up to where it is today.
Yeah, I've been keeping busy.
KRISPY UCCELLO: All right.
Well, thank you very much, Matt,
for being here today.
MATT GAUNT: Thank you.
KRISPY UCCELLO: Hopefully,
you'll have a safe trip back
to London and we'll have you
back again in the future.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah,
I'll be back.
KRISPY UCCELLO: Now, for those
of you who are watching us for
the first time, some of the
things you might want to check
out, we have a lot of back
episodes from 2012.
And you're also on another
Google Developers
Live Hangout regularly.
MATT GAUNT: So I'm with Rich
and Nick quite a lot of the
time on the Android
Office Hours.
So definitely check
those guys out.
KRISPY UCCELLO: Great.
Thank you for joining us.
MATT GAUNT: Cheers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
here from Google.
We're going to talk about
them in a second.
But we're here to help you,
answer your questions so that
this becomes a pretty enjoyable
event and you guys
can walk away feeling
good like you
accomplished something.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
and if you have any questions
about what it's like to work
for Google or any other
questions [INAUDIBLE].
KRISPY UCCELLO: --another
stat for you.
On average, about 300 million
people in the US watch about
five hours of TV per day.
Interesting?
You know what that is?
That's 166,000 years
of television
watched in a single day.
That's more than the entirety
of human history.
MALE SPEAKER: So some people
asking me whether this is a
real photo.
And the answer is--
it is a real photo of me
with a [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: It's a cool
hackathon combining YouTube
and TV technologies.
Welcome to everyone.
Talk [INAUDIBLE].
And folks are putting up all
their ideas and teams are
trying to form.
We're looking forward to
one hell of an event.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm getting
my code out.
I'm trying to recruit
people, so--
MALE SPEAKER: Well, you
know first prize is
that 55 inch LG TV.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: That was the best
presentation I've seen
here probably this week.
Probably this year
[INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: Wow,
high praise.
MALE SPEAKER: It was
great, though.
I enjoyed it.
It's going to be some of the
inspiration from what we do in
our presentation.
MALE SPEAKER: The point of our
app is going to be that it's
going to be like a challenge,
like physical challenges.
So instead of--
it's just supposed to be making
exercise a lot more fun.
So what you can do is you can
interact with your friends or
you can interact with people
all over the world.
You can find them
on the map and
then send them a challenge.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: Whatchya fixin'
up there, Jeremy?
That looks like a lot of guac.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, it's going
to be a little of everything.
MALE SPEAKER: We are going to
build a Google TV-related
application.
We don't know what it is yet,
but we're just trying to make
it work first and then figure
out from there.
MALE SPEAKER: Sure.
We're working on an app that
will be based inside
Salesforce.com or the
[INAUDIBLE] platform that will
allow companies to upload videos
to YouTube and then
automatically receive the stats
of how many people have
watched that video, liked it,
et cetera, all from within
Salesforce [INAUDIBLE]
and so on and so forth.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FEMALE SPEAKER: I hate
to disappoint you.
I'm here supervising three
different people [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
And what are they building?
FEMALE SPEAKER: One of them was
the cat videos that you
saw up front there.
The other one was connecting
with the EdTech students who
are interested in
furthering that.
And then the last one is going
to surprise me, so we'll see.
MALE SPEAKER: It's 4:10 PM, and
we're able to record from
a webcam using the upload widget
up to YouTube and pull
some stats on that video.
MALE SPEAKER: Cool.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: --all night?
MALE SPEAKER: Yes, I was.
MALE SPEAKER: And did you stay
up or did you sleep?
MALE SPEAKER: I'm not
sure actually.
Both.
MALE SPEAKER: You think you're a
humming bird of some sort at
this point?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
that's right.
MALE SPEAKER: So how
far along are you?
MALE SPEAKER: Pretty
much close, yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah?
You think you'll do any demo?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
I think so.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, good.
MALE SPEAKER: We're
doing pretty good.
We're where we wanted to be.
We had a late night until about
2:00 in the morning.
MALE SPEAKER: You look
a little sleep
weary, a little like--
I don't know where I am.
MALE SPEAKER: That's
usually how I am.
MALE SPEAKER: Morning.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Good morning.
MALE SPEAKER: You ready
for another
exciting day of hacking?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: Good.
FEMALE SPEAKER: As
ready as ever.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I am right now
just adding on a little page
where we can expand
on the search.
[INAUDIBLE].
To expand on the search, and
there's a toolbar for the more
popular searches and naming
categories to put as examples
of what you'd see.
MALE SPEAKER: So where
are we at?
MALE SPEAKER: We're
doing good.
We have a application that lets
teachers use Google TV in
the classroom and get feedback
from students by having the
students anonymously engage when
they don't understand.
And we have the view that lets
teachers set up the videos and
prepare the class, and also
the interface that the
students will see.
Right now, we're planning to
make a bring-your-own-device
interface so that students with
computers, cell phones,
tablets can engage through
the application.
We're doing pretty good.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Technology.
[INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: Number two.
How you guys doing?
MALE SPEAKER: 10-4.
Coding strong.
MALE SPEAKER: Coding strong?
MALE SPEAKER: We've done the
basic functionality and now we
are building the interface
to interact with it now.
I learn a lot with a few guys
on using the new API, the
YouTube API.
And they are learning a lot
about the Google TV SDK
integrate with the Android
[INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: You all set for
another day of coding?
MALE SPEAKER: I had this
awesome trick I was
going to do to you.
It's going to take me a little
while to build it though.
I'm ready to code.
We're going to win.
MALE SPEAKER: Excellent.
MALE SPEAKER: Fighting timers.
MALE SPEAKER: Fighting timers?
MALE SPEAKER: Right now, we're
trying to make [INAUDIBLE].
Effective controller--
[INAUDIBLE] controller.
FEMALE SPEAKER: They're doing
the hardcore stuff and I'm
just getting the presentation
ready.
So it's coming along
swimmingly.
They will because I believe
in the guys.
Go team.
MALE SPEAKER: But it's overly on
top of the live-stream TV.
So you can still watch the show,
but you can also watch
it interactively at
the same time.
MALE SPEAKER: We all understand
what we're doing
now, and our goal is clear, so
I think everyone is focused
and everyone's working on their
own piece of the puzzle.
MALE SPEAKER: HTML and CSS based
modules, that'll be the
building blocks of our pages,
while our partners are working
on our database schema.
And hopefully, within the hour
or so, we're going to be able
to start merging together.
MALE SPEAKER: Totally.
At this point, we've got a
bunch of it designed and
coded, and we're just going to
smush the two together and
everything will be magical.
MALE SPEAKER: Awesome.
KRISPY UCCELLO: Hi everyone.
Krispy here.
I'm going to walk you through a
basic tutorial on how to set
up your environment on Windows
so that way you can do Google
TV development.
So we're just going to launch
Chrome here and
maximize the window.
First thing we need to do
is install the JDK.
So this is a clean install
of Windows 7.
And I'm just going to
go to the Oracle
JDK download section.
And what we want to do is
download the latest JDK,
standard edition is fine.
And since this is a 32-bit
system, I'm going to be
downloading the Windows
x86 binary.
Don't forget to accept the
license agreement.
So we'll do that and download.
And so that'll take a second.
I've sort of sped
things up here.
While that's actually
downloading, I'm going to go
and get, not the ADK, that's the
accessory development kit
We're going to get
the Android SDK.
So just do a quick search,
get Android SDK.
And Android has done a wonderful
job of packaging up
all the tools we need.
So we're just going to download
the SDK, agree to the
terms of service.
Again, 32-bit.
And we're going to
download those.
While that's downloading,
why don't we
launch the JDK install.
So we'll just click here
and get this going.
And again, I've sped up some
of this because it takes a
little long, especially on
a virtualized instance of
Windows here.
So I'm just accepting pretty
much the defaults--
install the development tools,
source code, JRE.
And I leave all the path
settings the standard or the
defaults that are there.
So this could install and
set everything up.
The nice thing about this
installer is you don't have to
modify environment variables
afterwards.
So now that it's installed,
I like to use PowerShell.
You can use the standard
terminal, but I like
PowerShell because I
could [INAUDIBLE]
et cetera.
So we're just going to
launch this here.
Oh yeah, the after
install screen.
We can get rid of that.
And go back to PowerShell and
we're going to type in Java
dash version.
And we should see some
input which we do, so
we know it's installed.
That's great.
And I think our zip files
downloaded for the SDK.
So we'll just open this up.
And I guess we've got to back
out of this to install it.
So we'll just unzip
the directory.
Now, I like to put my tools
in a development folder.
So I'm going to create the
development folder.
Usually, I just put that
under my user name.
So Development.
All right.
And then I like to create
another folder for tools.
So create another folder called
Tools and hit OK.
And we're just going to extract
this zip file in there.
And this has everything you
need to get going with
development.
Again, I've sped this up a
little bit because a little
slow on the instance
I'm using here.
So once that is installed,
there's a couple things we're
going to need to do to sort
of get going with this.
So let's open the directory.
And we'll go into the Eclipse
folder which has a special
version of Eclipse that the
Android team has set up.
So we'll launch Eclipse and tell
Windows it's OK to run
it, and the Android Developer
Tools IDE will launch.
I like using this one, again,
because everything is sort of
pre-packaged, and the ADK tools
are already integrated
with this Eclipse instance.
So it just makes life
a little easier.
So again, in this case,
we're going to
create a new workspace.
I don't like accepting the
defaults because it puts it in
a weird place.
Inside our Development folder,
we are going to create a
subfolder, call it, I don't
know, GTV Workspace.
And that's where we're going
to store our projects.
So we'll just hit OK there.
I typically don't set the
default because I like to
create a lot of workspaces.
Your personal preference,
whether you want to use one
for all of them or not
is again your choice.
So yes, we'll send statistics
to Google.
And we'll just expand
this window.
And you can just close
this screen.
You can read all that
stuff if you want.
It's just how to use it.
And up here, we have the the
SDK Manager and the Virtual
Device Manager.
I'm going to launch the SDK
Manager because from here,
we're going to choose what sort
of SDK packages we need
to install.
So this is sort of an extra
little step here.
By default, the latest
is usually installed.
We need Android 3.2 installed
to do Google TV development.
And you'll notice there's a
Google TV add-on below there
that contains an emulator.
But we're not going to use
that in this video.
So everything else looks
pretty good.
So we're just going to install
these packages.
This might take, again,
a few minutes.
Oh, what's down here?
So I usually check if there's
any other additional extras I
want to add.
We might do some analytics
stuff,
so let's check Analytics.
And that way we can
use the Analytics
tool in future tutorials.
So everything else looks good.
Let's just install
these packages.
Going to accept all the
agreements, hit Install, and
that's going to proceed
to download.
So again, I've sped this up.
It might take a little longer
on your computer or it might
take less time.
I don't know.
So we'll let this install.
Going to ignore those
console messages.
And we close this.
Let's see.
We need to go in here.
We need to launch the Control
Panel because now that we have
the tools installed,
we actually need to
add them to our paths.
So we'll just go into the search
area here and we'll
type in environment variables,
and we'll click on Edit
Environment Variables which will
pop up our handy little
Environment Editor.
Just drag that over here and
click on the PowerShell.
And that will change our
Environment Variables.
So we're going to
edit the path.
But before we do that, we need
to know where our tools are
relative to the file system.
So I'm going to go into the
Development Tools, and then
you'll see in here that we have
the ADK bundles, so we'll
just change into
that directory.
And we'll see that we have
another folder, the SDK.
And then platforms.
Do we need anything
in platforms.
I don't think so.
Let's just double check.
Yeah.
We're good on platforms.
So I think we want
Platform Tools.
That's really what we're going
to be adding to our path
environment variables.
So let's go Platform Tools.
And you'll see in
here ADB exists.
So this is the correct
directory.
This is the one that
we want to use.
And from here--
OK, so we see ADB
is right there.
That means we want to take the
path that we're currently in
and we're going to add that
to our environment path.
So we just copy this.
You can right click on it
after you highlight it.
We'll go find the
path environment
variable and hit Edit.
And then we're just going to
tack it on at the end.
So with Windows, you just put
a semicolon at the end here.
Let's go to the end.
Semicolon, and then we'll paste
it in, Control V. And
we'll hit OK.
And then you'll have to hit OK
on the System Properties in
order for that to stick.
Otherwise, you might add and
it's not actually applied yet,
and you'll get frustrated.
So now, what we can do is we
can go ADP Connect and then
type in the IP address
of your Google TV.
So you can get that under
Settings, Network, Status.
You can see the Google
TV settings.
The other thing is, you'll have
to set up your Google TV
to accept the IP address of the
computer you're using to
connect to.
So that can be done from the
Settings, Application,
Development.
And then there's an area to
enter the IP address.
So you can see we're
connected here.
So let's go back here.
We're going to create
our first project.
Now, you could create an
Android virtual device.
We're not going to do that
in this tutorial.
Let's just create a new Android
package or project,
and we're going to call
this Hello Google TV.
Now, I like to change
package name.
It's good to do that and
not use the default.
So we'll just use crom
Krispy Android's TV.
And we'll call it Hello.
Hello GTV.
Sure.
Now, required SDK.
I like to put everything at 3:2
just because that makes
sure I'm targeting Google TV.
You can leave the compile width
at whatever the latest
version is.
It'll still target
the right SDK.
Up here, I leave all
the defaults.
It'll create a launcher icon,
activity, blah, blah, blah.
And you can fiddle around with
this and toy with it.
The default's pretty nice, but
you can differentiate your
apps by maybe choosing
clip art.
So we'll choose this guy here,
and let's see, it's square.
Purple background with
a yellow Android.
That will look cool.
So something that sort of stands
out on the screen.
Make it a circle, add
a little padding.
This is good for basic
development stuff.
So just something
to keep in mind.
Now, on this screen,
we're just going
to create an activity.
We're going to leave the
default, but you have lots of
other options here.
I recommend when you're
beginning, just start with
basic blank activities that
way you learn what to add.
We're going to leave the
defaults for the name.
That's the activity name,
the layout name.
And again, don't play
around with the
navigation type right now.
But just leave everything sort
of default here, because this
is just a light introduction.
And now that this project is
created, once Eclipse catches
up with me here.
So your project's going to get
compiled and it's going to run
through all the Android tools
and do the resource
generation, et cetera.
Just going to wait for the
layout here to load.
Again, I'm doing this on a
virtual instance, so it's a
little slower than it might
be on your computer.
So I like to choose the Galaxy
Nexus view here because it's
about 720p.
And if we rotate it on its
side and then choose the
Hollow theme, you've got sort
of what Google TV size is.
So this is pretty
true to form.
So we have Hello world.
And let's just fit this
to the screen.
And what we're going to do now
is we're going to run this.
And so if this connected to your
Google TV, you're going
to see Hello world pop
up on the screen.
So you've created your first
Android application.
And oh, what have we got here?
Oh, no virtual devices.
Oh, we disconnected.
OK.
So let's go back into
PowerShell, and we're going to
go ADB Connect.
So if this happens to you,
it's quite simple.
You can do ADB Connect and then
the IP address of your
Google TV, and you see it
showing up here now in the
Android Device Manager.
So we know that that's the
device we want to run it on.
We'll click OK, and this will
now run or package it up and
install it on your Google TV and
run it and we should see a
nice screen that says
Hello world.
If yours looks a little
different, maybe it has an
action bar or whatever,
don't worry.
The important thing is
that it's running
on your Google TV.
So now, we're going to play with
some of the properties on
here that just cover a few basic
things just to get you
started and whet
your appetite.
So the first thing is maybe we
want to change the text size.
So we're going to create
a new dimension here.
We'll call it Big text or
something like that.
Hit Font and we'll set it
to 44 device pixels.
So this will be pretty
large on the screen.
It's a good idea to keep your
font sizes large, especially
on TV, because your users are
about 10 feet away from the
screen and you want them
to be able to use it.
Now, don't make everything
that big, but--
We can see here, here's our
dimension that we've added.
And if you hold down the Control
key and click on it,
it will open the Dimensions
XML file.
So this is sort of
how Android keeps
everything separately managed.
So remember that you can Control
click and you can edit
this here if you wanted to.
So we'll change this
maybe to 64 now.
And if we go back and look
at the graphical
view, it's even bigger.
So it's always a good to isolate
and separate out all
of the different parameters
in your lance.
So I'm just moving this around
relatively out, and I'm going
to add I think another margin,
just to add some margin
space around it.
There's lots of options
you can play with.
There's lots of great
tutorials online.
So let's go to the
margin here.
And we'll click on this,
and we're going to
create a new dimension.
And we're going to call
this Fat margin, and
we'll set this to--
that looks good.
So we'll set that.
And you can see that the margin
has been created around
the text element.
So from here, if we were to run
this, we would see it on
the screen like that.
Let's drag another text object
onto the screen.
I'm going to just center this
sort of where the Hello world
was before.
So we'll drop that in there.
And what's cool is now that we
have these dimensions, we can
actually reuse these.
So if we go to Margin
and choose Fat--
whoops, what did I
do wrong here?
Let's click on that again.
Big fonts.
All right.
There we go.
We have the margin,
we have the fonts.
And now if we run this, we will
see on your Google TV
these two pieces of text.
So this is a good thing that
can get you started.
And stay tuned as we do future
episodes for more cool and
exciting things you can
do with your layouts.
We're going to talk about UI
a lot more in future ones.
But just to quickly recap, your
XML files get edited as
you play with the lance.
And it's always a good
idea to edit in here.
Now, in this case, I'm actually
getting a warning about--
what is this?
This is a string that needs
to be extracted.
So my content description, I'm
just going to Control 1 while
I'm highlighting it, and that
menu will pop up and I can
extract the string.
And then if we Control click on
it, we can see the strings
XML file and you can
see Large text.
And we could change this
to whatever we want.
So let's just do that now.
Google TV Rocks.
And we could save that.
And run it.
It And you can see
this on your TV.
So hopefully, that gets your
appetite whetted and you dive
in a little bit further.
[MUSIC PLAYING]